We all have that one friend, we just can’t
take anywhere with us without a little explanation
and a whole lot of embarrassment.
Nobody expected what would happen when the
SCP Foundation cross-tested SCP-682, the Hard
to Destroy Reptile, with SCP-082, a giant,
aggressive humanoid called Fernand the Cannibal.
When they presented Fernand with a tissue
sample of 682, he said, “Oh, splendid!
My friend lives!”
When he entered the containment chamber, 682
immediately attempted to flee from him, despite
Fernand claiming they were friends who went
way back - And, in fact, 682 had once been
his loyal steed.
After extended fighting, Fernand began to
ride 682, an experience the reptile found
supremely humiliating.
Once 082 left, the giant was delighted, and
SCP-682 said something about him that we can’t
repeat if we want to keep monetization on
this video.